from portion sizes to exclusives we
wanted to find out all the differences
between KFC in the U.S UK Japan and
India this is food Wars
so at the KFC in Japan you can order
your chicken pieces in one piece two
pieces three pieces four pieces five
piece bucket that comes with only leg
pieces in the UK you can get Buckets in
three sizes you can get a six piece add
pieces and the largest one of them all a
10 piece leg bucket 12 pieces or you can
get a 14 piece or 16 piece bucket it's a
lot of chicken
in Japan we have three drink sizes so we
have a small in the US our drinks come
in medium
and this is what a large drink looks
like here in India we don't serve cups
we just serve cans
[Music]
if you want you can also get half a
gallon bag of your favorite drink of
choice look at this thing
it's convenient so the fries are the KFC
in Japan come in three sizes so this is
smoked it's a regular fries and
back again the large
then we got
a box
let us now measure the latch to see how
much you get
now of course the US has a chicken
sandwich you can also get it spicy or
Classic this is classic I got this
little guy a chicken little look at this
guy huh there's a little guy because of
pickles Mayo so instead of a chicken
sandwich what we call ours is the
chicken fillet Burger
I think it's pretty much the same thing
it's like breaded and fried chicken
between two buns with some lettuce and
some mayonnaise we also have something
called the Zinger Burger which is pretty
much the same thing but the spice level
is amped up a little bit you can also
turn these Burgers into a tower burger
what that does is adds cheese and a hash
brown to the Burger which in my opinion
very worthwhile addition now we have
special sandwiches this one right here
is called Japanese style chicken cut
sandwich so let's take a look inside
it's got mayo and it's got cabbage and
chicken Cuts right there
hmm
oh this sauce is like soy sauce based
sauce and it's a little bit sweet and
this Mayo is also great with this sauce
this looks really small but
it has huge amount of chicken so if you
eat this you're gonna be full
and next one we've got chicken fillet
wow this is also huge all right so this
one right here is called black hot
sandwich
look at this it's like pepper mayo I
just tasted this paper Mayo but it has a
little like spiciness oh
oh man it's it's strong I wouldn't get
it be careful all right let's move on to
chicken sandwiches here in India we
don't have an American chicken sandwich
but we have a Zinger and a smaller
sandwich called a crisper cute the
crisper looks like it wants to grow up
and be a Zinger someday they also come
in two variants uh spicy crisper and a
Tandoori Zinger let's taste all of them
oh pretty young they've used a different
kind of mayonnaise here it has a bit of
sweetness to it and a spicy cooker then
and now for the legendary Zinger
um back in the day there were only two
fast food chains here in India it was
McDonald's and KFC and while McDonald's
had more affordable Burger options the
KFC Zinger was so delicious it was
always a treat to eat
mmm and it still is I love that they use
a whole boneless piece of proper Chicken
in there delicious Mayo it's so
delicious okay now let's try the spicy
variants this is the spicy crisper look
at this sauce it's almost blood red I'm
excited
oh my God
the sauce almost has a Schezwan taste to
it next up the Zinger but Tandoori
I love the fullness of the chicken that
comes in these burgers versus you know
like a minced chicken patty in other
restaurants there's so much bite to it
so juicy tender that all sounds amazing
stop you're going too fast I have to say
those sandwiches look delicious and I am
jealous all right moving away from
chicken India's KFC actually has
vegetarian alternatives for all our
Burgers there is a vegetarian crisper a
vegetarian spicy crisper and a
vegetarian Zinger now while India has a
majority population of non-vegetarians
around 70 percent there is a huge
vegetarian population which is why a lot
of fast food restaurants have to make
sure they have a lot of vegetarian
options on their menu to make it more
approachable and acceptable for all
people over here there's also levels to
vegetarianism over here there are I will
eat egg but not chicken vegetarians
there are I will eat fish but not lamb
vegetarians there are I will eat the
curry but not the pieces vegetarians
there are I am vegetarian only on
Tuesdays vegetarians there are I have
made a promise to God for this one month
vegetarians there are I am vegetarians
so you will all be vegetarian
vegetarians they're the weird ones and
we try not to talk about them which is
why KFC in India Brands itself as just
KFC there's no Kentucky Fried Chicken
anywhere here because obviously I'm not
going to go to a place that's named that
if I'm one of these many types of
vegetarians KFC in America has extra
crispy chicken this is the best type of
chicken I mean look at this I don't know
what they do to this but the skin is
practically falling off it is so crispy
and so delicious I love extra crispy so
much so we also have deep pack
so it's got kernel crispy and some
nuggets and boneless Kentucky and some
original chicken so this deep pack
becomes with this price so if you want
to have a little bigger one you can
order deep Barrel I mean it's double
amount of this deep back so it's gonna
be very big so this one right here is
called four piece Red Hot chicken box
and it comes with a pie and Fry
and a medium drink and actually we have
other box options like four piece half
cut and half original box and it comes
with price as well and six piece half
hot and half original box it comes with
fries again
so in Japan we have Torino's pack that
means chicken day it's on every 28th of
the month and two stands for knee and
eight stands for
and it becomes new one and niwa is
synonymous with
remains chicken so that's why it's
called chicken day okay let's start with
chicken in India apart from the crispy
chicken we also get Smoky Red Chicken
woof
wow I believe this is KFC's answer to
tandoori chicken if you guys don't know
what a Tandoor is it's basically a
cylindrical oven that they light up
using wood fire or charcoal and it adds
a really Smoky flavor to the meats or
breads that you cook inside of it I
doubt KFC's across the country have an
actual Tandoor but the flavoring
definitely smells like that the marinade
looks like that
oh my God that's actually pretty good
you know what KFC
pretty good job you have to remember KFC
is competing with a lot of mughlai
restaurants across every Indian City
and while this doesn't have as much of
that Smoky Char that a lot of Tandoori
kebabs have
it has a lot of flavor and the chicken
is quite juicy
good job it's super spicy though so if
you're somebody who can't handle spice
go a little easy on this one when an
Indian says something spicy it's spicy
the pot pie that they have here they're
not kidding when they say pie and the
pot pie how thick this is I gotta say
the pot pie actually looks quite good we
love meat pies here in the UK you'll
often see people tucking into like a
steak and kidney pie or a chicken pie
but yeah they should probably put that
on the menu over here I think with cash
in on the British Market speaking of big
dishes of stuff the famous bowl once
upon a time a KFC employee was like I
could have put everything into one dish
and call it a day and ta-da the famous
bull was born this has to be like three
pounds now Joe I'm glad you also think
that the famous bowl doesn't look that
great because to me that looks like a
nightmare we currently have a Nashville
hot chicken and hot tenders I went ahead
with the tenders I've just been informed
this was a big Tic Tac thing for a
minute something about biting and
crunching it I don't know anything about
that I can say just by holding this
there's no way these are crispy
[Music]
was that spicy it's kind of spicy I do
like this a lot
I'm gonna stop eating up
oh that's Heat's catching up with me
Slow Burn slow Builds on the heat all
right
so we've got two special Twisters so
this one right here is called pepper
mayonnaise twister
[Music]
it looks great
nine out of ten KFC thank you thank you
for making me happy so next we got oh
Teriyaki twister should be great it's
kind of gross
it's got mayo and Chrono crispy some
veggies and I hope this is teriyaki
sauce
mmm
it looks gross but it tastes
incredible 10 out of 10. congratulations
means delicious look how tiny those
Twisters are I could eat like three of
those easily easily all right so this
one right here is called Chrono crispy
is it only in Japan I cannot confirm the
difference between a kernel crispy and a
KFC chicken tender they call their
tenders kernel Crispies and we call our
kernel Krispies Chicken Tenders there's
a few other language differences like
instead of chicken tenders we call ours
chicken mini fillets it's been a while
since I ordered this one but it still
has crispy bits
good job Japanese KFC is technology
state of the art one iconic dish that
you'll find on the KFC India menu is
Biryani and so KFC India has taken a
very bold decision to launch their own
biryanis they come in four flavors
number one classic chicken nice and
crispy number two popcorn chicken number
three the spicy red chicken that I
really enjoyed and number four the veg
Patty which it's so tempting to just
push that to the side because veg
Biryani is already just a concept that
we not a fan of over here
but just for
just for now you can you can stay here
okay I'm gonna begin with the popcorn
chicken biryani which is just so
Blasphemous to begin with
um
it's not a Biryani it's
I'm so upset right now this one the
spicy Red Chicken
has a bit of that Tandoori vibe to it
they've really tried to over compensate
with the spices there's a lot of clove
flavor just to convince you you're
eating a Biryani so
go easy on that Curry
I could eat this like if I was hungry
not a Biryani though also use KFC that
you can't get in Japan are wings you can
get wings at the KFC in units of 6 12 24
or 48. so if the three wing flavors that
I got here are standard Buffalo the
honey barbecue and if you're a total
wuss
on sauce what's wrong with you yeah very
sketchy you can also get them in a
limited time Nashville hot sauce all
right so we have nuggets we have
three pieces five pieces and they come
with only kitchen our biscuit on the
other hand is just this southern style
not exactly a scone but kind of looks
like one from a distance dry cornmeal
biscuit
here we've got
KFC business it comes with honey maple
KFC
this is good the maple is a little bit
sweet for me mac and cheese I can't
believe you guys do not have macaroni
and cheese
love mac and cheese mashed potatoes and
gravy you don't have that in Japan guys
guys demand this from your Japanese KFC
you want the mashed potatoes and gravy
now we have a slightly different
approach to sides in the UK compared to
the US for example our corn comes on the
cob baked beans these are slightly
different to the regular beans that you
might put on toast in the UK they have
kind of a barbecue sauce flavor to them
and now for the quickest sauce talk ever
KFC sauce
then the KFC sauce is like a brown
mustard mayo yeah that sauce is good
there are a few sauces which are
exclusive to the UK for example we have
this spicy supercharger dip which is
kind of like a spicy mayo type thing we
have some sweet chili sauce garlic
mayonnaise another really good option
garlic Mayo on chips it's just fantastic
these three dipping Salsas so we've got
Barbecue Salt and
mastered and this pink one is called men
daiko Mayo men daiko means is like spicy
coduro and it's very popular case in
Japan this is actually great I'll dip
this
um
it tastes fantastic winner
India does not have too many exclusive
dips in fact we just have a veg eggless
mayonnaise and a Tandoori Masala
mayonnaise it's time to taste
I'm using the same hand because here in
India we don't eat with our left hand
if you're wondering why commenters you
let them know
why don't Indians eat with their left
hand
[Music]
well it's just mayonnaise so good job on
that
mayonnaise again with a little bit of a
sweet but also spicy kick to it I wish
we had more options especially
considering there are so many different
delicious chicken options I'd love to be
able to dip my tenders in more sauces
that is a weird sentence desserts are us
KFC you can get this chocolate chip
cookie recognize that guy it just looks
just like this guy
and finally a chocolate chip cake
here in India we have two exclusive
desserts a Choco mud pie and a coffee
mousse cake
oh boy just look at this cross section
my friend
next up coffee mousse cake
yeah
um these are
pretty average as desserts found drinks
there's a few that we can get that you
guys cannot over there in Japan the
first one is a beverage that I have yet
to make one human being who enjoys it
of course I'm talking about Sierra Mist
maybe gross the soda ever
so bad another drink that you can get at
KFC that you can't get in Japan and here
it is right here mountain is great when
I was in college I worked at a pizza
place I drink so much Mountain Dew I
threw up and now I'm drinking Mountain
Dew let's see if I can do it again my
favorite beverage Mountain Dew sweet
lightning
so good so good so here we've got
Japanese exclusive drinks this one right
here is
water
but it counts with this awesome tea pack
it's supposed to be hot but it's cold
and next one we've got coffee and this
one right here is roasted Rich coffee
it's a little bit better than that
normal coffee and here we got all gray
iced tea it's not sweet at all and next
one is melon soda it has bright green
color
foreign
horrible it's too sweet here is ginger
ale nothing special and the last one
it's not Channel refreshing orange
exclusive drinks in KFC India we have
mirinda which is an orange soda and Red
Bull let's talk about mirinda uh this is
a drink that really evokes Nostalgia 90s
kids
really know what I'm talking about when
I say
Miranda
the drinks are just normal nothing
special but chickens are Finger Licking
Good
now usually would have even more
exclusive menu items to show you but
unfortunately UK KFCs are currently
operating with a reduced menu here's
what you could normally find on the menu
at UK KFC
a vegan burger the big daddy burger
a range of chicken wraps
some rice boxes
onion rings curry sauce Crush thems and
a full range of hot drinks including
English breakfast tea
so let's talk about Christmas in Japan
so Christmas is one of the biggest
events in Japan even though about one
percent of Japanese people are
Christians we just enter Christmas as
just a fun event and as for KFC for
Christmas in Japan back in 1970s Japan
KFC launched a hugely successful
autovertising campaign called Canta
quinoa Christmas that's Kentucky for
Christmas and with that strong marketing
campaign it became so popular to have
KFC for Christmas in Japan and now about
3.6 million Japanese families eat KFC
for Christmas and talking about my
personal experiences yet when I was
young I would eat KFC for Christmas with
my family but when I started dating you
know Christmas makes the transformation
from a family event to couples event and
I'm looking for the the one who can
enter KFC for Christmas with me
in the UK a drum is 170 calories so in
Japan one drum stick of or oh
so in Japan one drumstick of original
chicken on average has 237 calories
chickens look in a little limp there
George in the U.S one stiff drumstick of
original recipe is 130 calories but
according to KFC's U.S site that's for a
53 gram piece now adjusting for the 87
gram piece like that of Japan the
calories go up to
210. does that make sense great now take
this bad boy and make them extra crispy
you got 270 calories
it's too many calories
um
not enough calories if you ask me but
Finger Licking Good I think KFC got to
George he keeps dropping that slogan are
they paying George I think that I think
George is getting some money on the side
from KFC oh my God if the George turns
out to be Colonel Sanders I will lose my
mind be sure to point out that the KFC
India website is in major need of an
update there is an FAQ page where people
have asked things like how many calories
does this chicken have or sometimes I
see red deposits in my chicken what is
it
and for almost all of these questions
the answers are just filler text so if
you ask me what those red deposits are I
genuinely don't know
unfortunately KFC in the UK doesn't
disclose its ingredients in the US our
original recipe chicken ingredients are
first with the fresh chicken it is
marinated with salt sodium phosphate and
a lot of sodium glutamate onto the
breading it's breaded with sweet flour
so like calcium phosphate maltodextrin
triglycerides natural flavor kernels
secret original recipe seasoning so KFC
in Japan doesn't disclose their
ingredients so we emailed their customer
support and this is what they told us
unfortunately KFC does not share a full
list of ingredients with the public so
what do we know about KFC well the KFC
India website has a couple of Clues we
know that all of our chicken is farmed
here and not imported and all of it is
100 whole muscle chicken
that means it's made from whole pieces
of chicken and not cut together minced
chicken like you find in chicken nuggets
in fact the website says they have an
open kitchen policy and what that means
is anybody can walk into a KFC and
apparently ask for a kitchen tour and
you can go into the kitchen look at
everything and ask as many questions as
you want Indian chicken farmers were
previously criticized for overusing
antibiotics as recently as 2018 the
Bureau of investigative journalism found
out that a lot of Indian farmers were
feeding cold steam to their chickens as
a growth promoter without any medical
supervision Coalition is known as the
antibiotic of The Last Resort holy
oh my God that's so funny thing and it's
only given to humans when other
antibiotics have failed so if we give
our chickens Coalition then the humans
who consume it might become resistant to
it in fact they can develop antibiotic
resistance superbug and that's not good
usually this sounds like the plot to a
horror movie what is he talking about
that is terrifying I'm gonna assume we
don't do that here and if we do oh God
but when a report came out talking about
the ill effects of Coalition India ended
up Banning it completely so we're safe
from Coalition at last
I kind of look like Colonel Sanders
right look at this guy
I'm a younger Colonel Sanders KFC is
doing any sort of The Adventures of
Young Colonel Sanders ad campaign
is this a face ticket sell chicken